as a script doctor what do you see most
screenwriters get wrong with the second
act of their screenplays
writers
sort of
forget to keep surprising the audience
you know they write this killer First
Act you know where maybe the first three
pages are really engaging the exciting
incident is great but then the story
just like becomes this low and they're
kind of just making us wait to act three
where they'll deliver all of the big
things again they sort of forget that
act 2 is kind of the bulk of your story
that central conflict should be in
motion so
they tend to kind of forget that they
should be tracking the protagonist Arc
through that a lot of times one of the
things I see is that they do set up the
protagonist well in act one right they
set up their core wound they flaw we
know what they need to overcome but then
we don't actually see the evolution of
that enact two we just see a change in
act three that kind of suddenly happens
because oh it needed to happen because
it was set up that's what act 2 should
be about we should be seeing that
central conflict evolve we should see
ups and downs and that emotional Journey
the midpoint should throw us in a
different direction and help us see the
growth in the character
help us see that change that will happen
if we're talking about Juno for example
she has this ups and down when she's
talking about whether she should keep
the baby or not you know and act two is
really good because she goes into the
subplot you know with the potential
adopted father you know that they start
bonding and they have this kind of
friendship where the adopted dad kind of
starts re-stembling Juno if you pay
attention to like the little details he
starts dressing more and more like her
which is a brilliant thing that they did
in the movie you know the costume
Department was great about that so they
Implement that that's one of the things
in the second act that you should always
bring into things that subplot that kind
of revives the story after the midpoint
because that's one of the problems with
Act 2 right we always say that act 2 is
where things get kind of like lull and
boring because it's kind of long so you
should bring new things into the mix if
you're thinking about Back to the Future
for example after the midpoint where all
of the excitement is about getting back
to the future and everything happening
we get the subplot of the parents right
he needs to get his parents back
together or he won't exist in present
time so that's where things get
interesting with kind kind of an outside
story which is the parents this love
subplot of bringing them together and
like the dance and everything and that's
what you should be giving to your story
you should but at the same time that
supplement still reflects on his
emotional Arc we are not forgetting
about it he still needs to grow and
understand because part of his core
wound and Back to the Future is that
Marty is kind of like fed up with his
family and doesn't like what he has you
know he's bored he doesn't get it he
needs to kind of fall in love again with
his parents and the relationship they
have and he does that through helping
them fall in love in the past so he'll
exist in the future but then when he
actually gets back to the future and the
resolution of that movie we get that his
family has kind of improved right the
relationship with the parents then
everything is much better because he
played a part in that past
but that's the beauty of it we're still
tracking his Arc even through that
subplot he's still growing and evolving
so we see that change in him at the end
act two in a movie would be different
than act two in a TV series yes well it
depends on what you're thinking if
you're thinking of
hour or an hour long show right usually
hour-long shows have a teaser and five
acts and a half hour show has a teaser
and three Acts so they're kind of
structured a little different and yes
obviously we have streaming these days
where we don't technically see acts
because we don't see commercial breaks
but I believe that writers should still
kind of be writing with that Concept in
mind whether they put that on their page
or not because that helps you track the
emotional Arc
so I always say that when you're
analyzing television and when you're
writing a pilot
um whether you keep the ACT breaks or
not on the page which you can or can't
do whatever you decide
Every Act out should map your
protagonist's emotional Arc so you
should always end an arc on your
protagonist and tracking that Arc so if
you're thinking about a pilot you're
tracking how let's say Breaking Bad
you're tracking Walter's journey into
becoming
whoever he's going to become right so
the different act breaks and Breaking
Bad would relate to you know finding out
he has cancer and then deciding he's
going to reach out to Jesse Pinkman and
things like that you know always
tracking him and that Arc and change
that they're doing so in that sense if
you're kind of like trying to compare
the Arc of TV versus the art the accent
TV versus the ax on features sort of
like the problem of act two that you see
in a feature compared to television
would be either act two and a half hour
or acts kind of like three in like an
hour long show which is kind of like in
the Middle where you're like oh where
are things going I'm showing like the
subplots that's where you should
introduce really your subplots and your
secondary characters because in
television your Supporting Cast is
really important because they're still
part of the core cast of your show so in
a pilot obviously you try to focus more
on your protagonist because that that's
really who the story is about and then
maybe in future episodes you'll focus
more on the other characters but you
should still introduce all of that in
the pilot and it's sort of like in the
Middle where you should bring them in
and kind of start showing like the B C
or D stories with them and all of the
subplots to really lighten things up
when things are getting you know like oh
my God we're getting a little bored
about this like main story of the
protagonist let's bring in The
Supporting Cast and reflect the same
themes or things that they're going
through through them and help them see
where they're going
and so is that something you spend the
most time with in with a lot of new
writers is working on that second act
yes that's a lot of the the work I would
say especially you know tracking that
Arc tracking the protagonist showing
that they need to be tracking things and
not just expect a sudden change at the
end you know uh let's say this morning I
was working on a script for a writer and
I was writing my notes and everything
and they have a great setup for uh what
they want the character to do you know
it's a common of age story uh so usually
you know the teenager has to grow and
learn something because something
happens to them right they could be
injury or they could have a heartbreak
or whatever by the end but then act two
kind of doesn't show us any of that
growth what you want is to track all of
that so give us little a little journey
show us why we should be watching this
and how that ending is going to come so
for example if you have someone that
needs to overcome a stutter
track that through Act 2 before they
have you know the big speech that they
might give in act three where they're
not stuttering anymore so show us all of
the obstacles they have to face perhaps
they fall for someone and then makes
them you know start even more then they
get an other obstacle in the way because
they have to do a presentation they're
set up for a project at school and
they're like how am I going to do that I
won't be able to present and then my
crush is going to be watching me it's
going to be even worse so give us those
tidbits that keep tracking that arc when
you're setting up you know those uploads
of the love story and how am I going to
handle that if I'm looking at a person
that makes me stutter even more and then
set up that they have to do a project
because then by the end you know we're
expecting that we're expecting that the
promise coming or the project they have
to give a speech or something like that
tease that so we know that they're
working towards something and we're
tracking that evolution